Joe good morning thanks for joining us
thank you Dan good to catch up with you
I've enjoyed the conversation this
morning you guys have had we'll get to
that in a moment controversial and could
be groundbreaking but our i-team is on
that report from from Joe from his
college days now if your Redskins
management what do you want to happen
that best benefits the team with Kirk
Cousins well I think you want to try and
work out a deal that's that makes sense
for everybody and with people is the
question I get all the time what are the
Redskins going to do with Kirk Cousins
it's almost like what's Kirk Cousins
going to do with the Redskins simply
because the Redskins don't only have to
sign Kirk if they commit 24 million to
them in a franchise tag which they have
then you still have to Sean Jackson
Pierre Garcon Chris Baker you still need
defensive help on the other side of the
ball there's a lot of pieces that need
to be put together on that football team
and people that need to be signed to
commit money to even though the caps at
166 I would think that in earnest now
they should start the negotiations up
until July 15th because after that he's
committed and the only the only negative
on Kirk's side is number one Matt
Cavanaugh has taken over as a
coordinator so I don't know he's gonna
put the kind of numbers up because Matt
will probably want to run the football
more as a football team they'll want to
run the football more so maybe you're
not going to see 4,500 yards which
somebody'll say well see I told you he
couldn't but I think he's a franchise
quarterback I think he deserves
somewhere between 110 and 120 million
but now it has to be spread out over a
period of time the big thing Dan is
what's the bone is going to be and
what's the injury guarantee that's
normally about 45 to 48 percent of the
contract those are the guarantees take
for example Tony Romo's cap numbers 24
point 714 guaranteed that's the end of a
contract guys never see that so I think
the Redskins are trying to put together
a deal where it works for them from a
business standpoint but also is fair to
Kirk based on market value but how
difficult is it to build a team around
Kirk Cousins with that salary of Kirk
Cousins well with the cap going to 166
it may not be that difficult you're
probably going to lose at least one of
the
Seavers Pierre or Deshawn that's sort of
a given what's you know what's Chris
Baker gonna get as a defensive lineman
what's it going to the big question is
what's it going to cost you in the free
agent market to upgrade your secondary
if you're going there because the draft
now is insignificant when it comes to
numbers the the draft numbers are so
little I mean take a look at Dax salary
as an example and by the way dak and
Kirk were both fourth round picks I
agree with you you don't have to reach
in in any of these drafts none of these
kids coming out today to me a warrant a
first-round pick now they'll go because
of need but nobody's really in the
position to say okay that's the guy I
think they have to really seriously
consider franchising Kirk which I didn't
think they would do but they may have to
just to buy a little more time I'm
talking to Joe Theismann yeah I I think
it felt like Washington could have
wrapped this up with Kurt Kurt cousins
last year and I don't know if they were
rolling the dice Joe of just saying
let's see if he can do it in
back-to-back years did is that the sense
you get from what happened that is and I
think that was the sentiment that I felt
from you know from reading things and
hearing things that the organization
said let's see what you can do well
you're right they rolled the dice he
rolled the dice and and he came up seven
and they came up craps at this point but
now it's not to say that a deal can't be
done but what's impressive about this is
in this day and age where everybody
wants to see what someone else is saying
you haven't heard a word out of Kirk's
camp and you haven't heard a word from
the Redskins and as long as there's
silence I think there's dialogue when
things start to get a little more public
then it becomes a little bit of more of
a problem do you have any doubts about
Kirk Cousins I don't I think you know we
forget he's young yeah everybody wants
things right now I mean let's instant
satisfaction you know everybody say okay
let's see what Dax gonna do in his
second year and and then you know Kirk
has to prove himself he himself a
quarterback like Kirk Cousins there
aren't many of them in the league Dan I
mean we have we have 32 football teams
there's probably a dozen of them that
give you a chance to get to the playoffs
and maybe have a shot at a championship
and young ones have to continue to
develop but you know you look at what
luck has gone through and the money they
committed to him I'm that's going to be
the UM excuse me that's going to be the
contract that everybody's holding up and
looking at and saying hey look at this
number you can't do that I think each
team has to look individually at what
they can afford to do to support the
organization to have a chance to win I
certainly think Kirk Cousins has like I
say the value that I believe he is he
should be compensated in a fair way but
it's a two-way street you know you have
to understand that the organization
needs people too and it can't be all
about you all right settle this
legendary story Joe Joe Theismann
finishes runner-up for the Heisman in
1970 1970 Chris okay and as the story
goes the sports information director
Roger yes he he ordered you to change
your name because your name was Joe
Theismann and he said let's change it to
Theismann because it rhymes with Heisman
so walk me through this of when you got
approached and then how it played out
from there it was before by senior year
we'd had a really good junior year so
before my senior year Roger calls me in
the office he said Joe how do you
pronounce your last name I said it's C's
Minh he said no it's not it's it's now
Theismann I said no it's not it's C's
Minh he said no no it's Theismann so I
said give me the phone so I called I
picked up on call my dad hey I get my
dad's on the phone I said dad I got a
question for you it's far away Joey you
know typical Jersey guy hey far away son
I said alright dad how do you pronounce
our last name and there's like this
silence on the phone and my dad comes
Isis are you okay I mean you know you're
you're starting your senior in college
you know how to pronounce your last name
what's going on I said I'll explain it
later just tell me how do you pronounce
our last name he said these nice up I'll
call you later I'll get up I said Roger
look my last name statement I know I
just got home my dad he said Joe there's
a trophy out there called the Heisman
Trophy we think you have a chance to win
that trophy and we're gonna sort of help
you we're not going to count on just
your athletic ability nor the reputation
of the University of Notre Dame we think
just by changing the pronunciation of
your last name from thieves Matoo
Theismann to Ryan with Heisman we think
we can get you that trophy
now this is the question that was posed
on your show a little bit earlier
why didn't I change it back well I
called my grandmother who was the
matriarch of our family and we're from
Germany and so I called my grandmother
and I said granny look they're thinking
about changing the pronunciation of our
last name from these men to thighs and
she said well Julie let me tell you this
she said the correct pronunciation is
heisman and it's closer to it so I'm
okay with it so I got the blessing from
my grandmother and that's why I kept the
name weird where it is so that's that's
the whole story in the true story so
it's tais Minh its placement that's
correct - yep and you finish with
anything by the way and you finish
runner-up that year it was an
interesting year in quarterbacks when
you think about it Archie Manning Rex
Kern out of Ohio State
Dennis dumb it at a UCLA Chuck Hickson
out of SMU Dan Pastorini out of Santa
Clara
you know Jim was at Stanford I was a
Notre Dame it was when they talked about
that class of 83 quarterbacks but you
have to go back a little bit then we had
a pretty decent class in in 70 also who
had a better class we have more Super
Bowls you tell me well okay the 84 draft
had Elway and Marino by Todd Blackledge
Tony Eason ken O'Brien so it's a little
top-heavy there yeah because Elway in
Marina and you guys showed you and
Plunkett Peniston who else was in there
at one Super Bowls nobody oh so if you
unplug it okay so you guys got three yep
see it's interesting comparison of class
I'm late
well I think always the best quarterback
of all time you think he's the best of
all time well okay Brady's the most
decorated I'm talking about athleticism
at that position what what he was doing
when he was doing it with an offense
that wasn't very good and I I think
Elway let's I don't have a problem if
you want Brady and I get Elway I'm okay
with that or vice versa
I just for a long period of time I
always thought Elway was the best
quarterback I ever saw I think that's a
fair assessment and an ex
an explanation as to why you believe
that I think tom is and the reason I say
that is I look at the people that he has
played with I think I thought how he
long did a great job and one of the
pregame shows during the Super Bowl and
sort of highlighted the amount of change
that has occurred around Tom's position
46 different receivers I think 30-some
running backs but yet the constant there
has been Tom Brady now normally I would
say and this was this goes over to what
you were talking about trading Kirk
Cousins to San Francisco I always
believe that the quarterback position is
the single most dependent position on
the field and in Toms case he becomes
sort of the antithesis to that because
he is the most important thing that's
held I think that frenzy and in coach
Belichick but I listen going to Kirk
Cousins one more time to trade him to
San Francisco would be foolish on the
49ers part because they need so many
more things absolutely I think that
would be that would just be just because
you want to marry somebody up with a
coordinator that knows him as a matter
of fact if Colin Kaepernick winds up
staying in San Francisco which I think
he will remember Kyle Shannon had Robert
Griffin the third in Washington when he
came out so they're they're somewhat
similar in their athletic skills and
their ability I think Colin Maxon throws
better out of the pocket than Robert has
because he hasn't had a chance to grow
into it but Kyle had something to work
with with cap out there and Gabbard as
well so he's got you know they've got
quarterbacks it's not like they need so
many more pieces around it he's Joe
Theismann Joe great to talk to you again
thanks for joining us thanks Dan always
a pun Joe Theismann the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience
[Music]